this is what air travel looked like
earlier this year
but when the pandemic hit flights were
grounded
daily trips between new york city and
london dropped from 30 flights per day
to five
and the world's busiest route from
singapore to kuala lumpur
was cut to just two flights a day a
travel ban
we will close our border travelers will
no longer be permitted to cross the
border
before the slew of pandemic related
restrictions
travel and tourism accounted for about
10 percent of global gdp
and now countries are looking for ways
to restore some of that air traffic to
help speed up economic recovery
so destinations are teaming up to create
so-called travel bubbles
or what are also known as corridors or
airbridge
are all essentially the same thing is an
agreement between two destinations
two countries for a safe reopening of
travel the critical part of a travel
bubble
no 14 day quarantines on both ends we
would only go on a trip if we didn't
have to quarantine for 14 days
there's been a lot of chatter around
loosening travel restrictions
but not all of them qualify as travel
bubbles
for example new york city and london
discussed streamlining restrictions but
it wouldn't technically be a travel
bubble
because both cities would still have
required a short quarantine
singapore has been one of the most
active in setting up arrangements that
allow quarantine free air travel between
destinations
i believe it is the first of its kind in
the world
singapore has created no quarantine
options for travelers and so far
seven countries have signed up
here the steps to flying quarantine free
and wide travel bubbles could be one
part of reopening the global economy
during a pandemic travel bubbles are
meant to find a balance between two
extremes
letting people come and go freely while
risking further spread of the virus
and the opposite where your borders are
aromatically closed no one in there went
out
where the economy is suffering
enormously mario hardy is a travel
industry consultant
and he says travel bubbles can safely
ease countries into gradually reopening
their economies
when it was first mentioned people yay
that's fantastic that's a great solution
for us to reopen
but after a lot of research people
realize actually
it's not that simple hardy says if both
destinations have been successful at
containing the virus
laying the groundwork can be easier
assuming you have a good control on both
ends
that's one take on the on the list of
criteria
second you need to have a good
healthcare system
in both respective destinations so you
take the box on that one
the first type of bubble singapore has
rolled out with its partners is
specifically for government officials
and business travelers
before anyone can book a plane ticket
they first need a specific document
probably the most important would be you
need to be sponsored by
the local company to kind of invite you
over to the
country georgian lee is a consultant for
hotel and resort development projects
before the pandemic 95 of her job
required traveling on business trips
after working from home for eight months
she took a trip from singapore to seoul
in early november
lee brought documents to the airport
including her test results and an
itinerary that she had to stick to
now you need to also establish a safety
protocol
between the two destinations well he
means testing
we had to take a total of three tests so
like a
pre-departure one within the 72
hours before you leave and then
one upon arrival in south korea and one
upon arrival back in singapore
after lee landed in seoul she remained
in isolation for less than 24 hours
while waiting for her test result
after she was confirmed negative lee
downloaded an app to her phone and
headed outside
when you go to restaurants or shops you
scan a qr code
to register yourself there would be
people
actually calling you to check if you
have any symptoms
in late november singapore and hong kong
were ready to launch a different kind of
travel bubble with far fewer
requirements
travelers wouldn't need a sponsor letter
or a fixed itinerary
but they'd still need to take three
tests and download the tracking app
if it is successful then some of the
protocols might be a bit more relaxed
the
number of flights will certainly
increase there's an immense desire to
travel
but just two days before the launch a
surge in cases in hong kong prompted
both cities to delay the travel bubble
for two weeks
hardy says countries in asia have been
watching the singapore hong kong travel
bubble
as a model for reopening airways safely
only to be reminded that any planning
during a pandemic is difficult
meanwhile other governments are taking
tentative steps
for instance a potential travel corridor
between the uk and the united arab
emirates
may happen when the lockdown in britain
ends in early december
we do encourage destination to follow
the model that actually singapore is
doing and a few others within the region
have already put these plans together
and has communicated them to the private
sectors in the respective countries
and that is really helpful for
businesses at least to have a plan
until there's a vaccine hardy says
travel arrangements that emphasize
testing over quarantines can be one of
the best ways to help restart economies